[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hello, and
welcome to Talks at Google.
Today's person to talk to
is Mr. Jonathan Safran Foer.
Usually, people say, this
person needs no introduction,
and then they fall into
a long introduction.
I will try to
avoid this pitfall.
So please, Mr.
Jonathan Safran Foer.
Good afternoon.
I'll try to just go quickly
a couple of questions
on each and every book that
you wrote over the years.
And so the first
one will definitely
be "Everything is Illuminated,"
published in 2002.
And it is definitely
a fiction book,
yet as far as I
understand, it is
somewhat of an
expansion of a thesis
that you wrote beforehand.
So my question is,
in your view, how
accurate is this book
when it describes
all the atrocities
done by the Ukrainians
while little help
from the Germans?
And how much would you like
us, as readers, to treat it
as really a true thing?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: Well,
thank you, first of all,
for coming out.
It's a very grave
question to begin with.
SPEAKER: It only gets worse.
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: Yeah.
I feel a little tonally
out of my wheelhouse here.
It started when I arrived.
I had to pee very
desperately, as you know.
And I was, like, medevaced
to the men's room.
And above the urinal
is a document.
And I literally couldn't
tell if it was a joke or not.
I think it was a joke.
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
SPEAKER: Probably,
it's not a joke.
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER:
I think it was a joke.
It was something
about the difference
between debugging something
and some other word
that I didn't understand.
And look, it was a joke
one way or the other.
Either it was an
intentional joke,
or it was an accidental joke.
I think it was an
intentional joke about,
here we are at the
urinal and we're
going to treat it like we might
treat coding, or something
like that, if that's even
a word that you guys use.
Or it was an accidental
joke, in the sense
that I am going to seriously
ask you to think about something
while you're peeing, which
is entirely possible,
because there were
disposable toothbrushes.
And there are a
lot of suggestions
that one might continue to think
beyond the standard parameters
of a work day here.
In any case, you're
asking me about tone
and the tone in that book.
And it is a work of fiction.
And sometimes in fiction,
one has to, or one does,
move away from a kind
of journalistic truth
to get toward an
experiential truth.
So my second book, for
example, has a nine-year-old
who does quite a bit
of the narrating.
If I were to go to a
playground and take dictation
from a nine-year-old, I would
have an unassailably realistic
portrait of a nine-year-old-- a
journalistically accurate one.
But if you were to then read
that, you might think either,
this is boring, or
it just doesn't sound
like a nine-year-old to me.
And it's one of the
strange things, too.
And it's something
that perhaps you guys
wrestle with in your own ways--
the difference between something
being true and feeling true
or the difference between
information and substance.
And so I'm trying to create,
as a novelist, a substance that
imparts feeling,
that provokes ideas,
and that offers
an experience that
is beyond the kind of
scientific account, let's say.
That having been
said, there are--
and I'm willing to depart from
the scientific or journalistic
account, in order to make
it feel a certain way, most
of the time.
But there are some
times when I'm not,
when I want to be faithful
to history, for example.
And so in the case
of that book, I
did want to be
faithful to history.
And I would have, even if
it weren't personal history.
But it happened to
be personal history.
And so that was one of the,
I guess, responsibilities
or burdens that I felt.
SPEAKER: Interestingly
enough, something
like three years after the
publishing of the book,
it came out as a film as well.
So I'm wondering,
were you involved
in any way in the film?
And did you like it?
Or what was your opinion
on what was going on there?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: I
was only barely involved.
I came to know the
writer and director--
the same person-- quite well.
We became very good friends.
And so my involvement
was more as a friend than
as a collaborator
in the project.
And I did like it.
I was very, very
grateful that it
was made, because the scale
of film, the scale of screens
dwarfs the scale of paper.
And whether that makes
a writer happy or sad
is a separate
conversation, perhaps.
But it definitely makes a writer
happy when the world of screens
is brought into
the world of paper.
And so having a film
adaptation made of your book
is the best thing that
can happen to a book,
short of Oprah liking it.
But that's its own screen.
She is big, because
she's on the screen.
SPEAKER: OK.
So let's move forward three
years later into this book
that probably everyone in the
world has read at least once.
And if you haven't, you
should feel very shameful.
This book-- and again, in a
way similar to what happened
in the first book and
also in the newest book--
revolve around
major catastrophes
or all kinds of atrocious
thing that happened.
And I was wondering, why
does it happen in your books?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: Well,
I would say the same thing
about the days of my life
as I would about my books.
When was the last time
you turned on the news
and there wasn't, if not a
catastrophe, then a tragedy
to give you pause and
also to make you reflect
on yourself, both in terms of
the scales of your domestic
or personal tragedies or
catastrophes when compared to
or in the context
of what's going on
in the world and
the various ways
that we can become
confused about scale?
That's something that
happens with the characters
in this book here.
I am quite often a
confusion of when
there is a Syrian boy washed
up on the beach, what am I
then to do with the kind of
passive aggressive exchange
I had with my wife
the night before?
Dismiss it entirely, or
go back into it because
of a gratefulness for
being alive and wanting
to do as much as I can with
my life, knowing what I know
about the horrors of life?
So in each of my books--
and including the
nonfiction book,
which you didn't mention,
"Eating Animals,"
about factory farming--
there are these horrors
that force characters
to make decisions.
And I guess I have been
interested in the ways
that people walk around with all
kinds of ideas of who they are,
the things we think
we're thinking about
or think we're feeling,
which are often
just expressions of how we
want to think of ourselves
or who we want to
be or how we want
other people to think of us.
And it takes, often, a crisis
to reveal who we actually are.
SPEAKER: OK.
So again, going back
to really this book,
I remember, again, from
my personal experience,
I read it, more or
less, when it came out.
And I was feeling [INAUDIBLE].
I was 90% immersed in
what was going in the book
and 10% amazed at how
good this book is.
But when I reached page 269 in
my version, there was this--
probably, again, you
might remember there's
three pages of numbers--
of digits.
And I wouldn't start reading it.
I don't want to bore you.
But it starts with 69, 62, 63.
And this is the dial tone
of this grandfather who
doesn't speak, and he uses
the dial tone to communicate.
And I remember, again, my
friend and I trying, of course,
to decipher it.
So we were sitting
there and said, OK, we
wouldn't use any software,
because you probably
wouldn't like us to use one.
So we sat there and
trying, reading.
And we managed to go
something like, I don't know,
four or five lines.
And I said, probably
this is enough.
But I was wondering--
first of all, again,
nobody's listening.
Can you tell us, does it really
become random at some point?
Or can we read it
the entire thing?
What's going on there?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER:
Who can remember?
I wrote that so long ago.
SPEAKER: Would you like
me to read it to you?
Maybe you'll remember?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER:
Almost no memory of it.
SPEAKER: 64.
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER:
It is what it is.
What I can say is, the point
of it is not to decipher it.
The point of it is a kind
of expression of just
frustrated communication.
And that is true in
"Everything is Illuminated."
The hero of the book-- although
there is somebody who is named
the hero--
but the actual hero of the book
is Alex, this young Ukrainian
who is a frustrated communicator
in a pretty extreme way.
He speaks in a stilted,
very jarring English.
And then there's
frustrated communication
throughout "Extremely Loud."
And that's maybe the
best example of it.
And then also in "Here
I Am," characters
who have secret
languages between them
or who then secretly know
languages and people who
are unable to
express themselves,
but in certain
contexts and venues,
like one of the sons,
Sam, who's 12 years old,
who spends almost
all of his time
playing this second
life kind of game
called "Other Life,"
which has, really,
its own unique
language of interacting
and then the
husband and wife who
have their own sort of, again,
secret language-- like code
words for things that each
knows means something else.
When the kids are
in the backseat,
sometimes they will spell
out their conversations
so the kids can't
understand them.
I guess it's not a
coincidence that someone
who devotes himself to
language would question
the effectiveness
of language maybe
more than other people would.
And I think that
that is one example
of many of my playing out that
questioning through story.
SPEAKER: OK.
So you want to tell me the real
answer offline while nobody's
really listening?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: I just
told you the real answer.
I told you the real
question maybe.
SPEAKER: Yeah, probably so.
And by the way, this book was
turned into a movie as well.
So what do you think is
appealing in your books
to directors?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER:
Well, it's like, there
are people on Earth who have
been struck by lightning twice.
And to ask them,
what do you think
is appealing about
you-- maybe you
have a mouthful of
cavities or something
or you just happened
to walk near the ocean
during thunderstorms.
I just got very lucky.
I actually don't
think there's anything
that is particularly
appealing about the books,
in the sense of being
ripe for adaptation.
It just happened.
I don't really know why.
But I'm grateful that it did.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
OK, so we're moving five
years later from a book
that everybody read
to a book that I don't
know how many people read.
It's called "The
Tree of Codes"--
this one.
Again, I had a hard time
even getting a copy of it,
due to the fact that maybe
not too many people read it
or read about it.
Would you like just
to tell us a tiny bit
of what made you do it?
And how do you expect--
not to expect.
How do you imagine
a reader handling
this art, piece of art--
whatever you call it.
JONATHAN SAFRAN
FOER: Well, handling
is the perfect word,
because it's a book that's
meant to be handled.
You found it on Amazon.
What you didn't find
is a Kindle version
of it-- an ebook version.
I was approached by a--
I got a phone call one day.
I remember exactly where I was.
And I was in my office.
I was trying to write a novel.
And I got a phone call
from somebody who said,
I'm starting a publishing
house in England,
and we're going to do these kind
of literary visual crossover
books-- art books.
And I can't give you an advance.
I can't promise
good distribution.
We're not going to
market the book.
But I can make any
book you want to make.
And there was something
about that that just--
I don't know if I wanted to
challenge her certainty that we
can make anything
you want to make,
or if I just found it to be a
really appealing invitation.
But we started to work together
and came up with this idea.
It might be worth holding
it up and showing people,
because it's easy to
understand when you see it,
but it's very hard to
understand when it's described.
So I took a book
that already existed,
which was Bruno Schulz's
"Street of Crocodiles."
I don't know if you can see.
And I had die cut,
out of the book, words
so that the words
that remain tell
a completely different story.
If you haven't heard of it, it's
because what she said was true.
We're not going to
distribute it very well.
It was a hard book to make--
a very hard book to make.
There's actually a great
video you can find on YouTube,
I think, of the production
of the book, which
is a kind of pleasure
in and of itself.
But they didn't print
a huge number of them.
And that's it.
SPEAKER: So again, and I
saw in one of the interviews
that you--
one of the statements which
struck me as really interesting
was, "This is a book that
remembers it has a body."
So again, would you
like to elaborate?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: I
actually didn't say that.
It was the artist
Olafur Eliasson
who said that as a
blurb for the book.
But I think he
meant that we often
forget that books are
things, are artifacts,
and that they have qualities.
The margins in the
page are a quality.
The font is a quality.
The cover, of
course, is a quality.
The way books
smell is a quality.
The heft of a book when
you're in bed or in a bathtub
or on the sofa is a quality.
And ebooks, great as they
can be for certain things,
lack all of those qualities,
or at least they're diminished.
It's an interesting
question in life.
What do we get in exchange
for the loss of qualities,
because we're increasingly
living in a world
without qualities?
And some of them seem
awfully benign or silly even
to mention.
Like, phones don't
have buttons anymore.
There are representations
of buttons on a screen.
Buttons have qualities.
They make a clicking
sound sometimes.
Sometimes they put up a
little bit of resistance.
Sometimes they make each
letter feel a little bit more
individualized than
a virtual keyboard.
So those may not matter at all.
Those examples
probably don't matter.
But man, are there
a lot of examples.
And I'm sure that's-- or I hope
that's something that you guys
wrestle with all the time as
you create the future of human
experience and human
thought and human culture.
Who is remembering qualities?
It's clear who's
remembering expediency.
It's clear who's remembering
profit, profitability.
the significance of information,
or at least the significance
of collecting information.
But who is
remembering qualities?
Because I would bet, to
just about the last person
in this room, qualities are
what make us feel human.
I think quality is
what makes love, love.
It's what makes fear,
fear and makes hope, hope.
I wouldn't want to
forget about those.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
By the way, an interesting
thing that happened to me
with this book was that--
preparing for this interview,
I talk with my kids.
And I told them about this book.
And I thought I would
amaze them and never
seen such a thing before.
And they told me, oh, in third
grade, we did such things.
So I wonder if you
started the trend here
that every elementary school--
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: It
resembles a children's book
in a lot of ways.
Children's books are
wonderful objects oftentimes--
like pop-up books.
It's kind of amazing, actually.
A novel might now cost
$30 in a bookstore.
And if you go to the children's
book section, for, like, $6,
you can get a book that has all
of these full color and things
that come out and
they make noises.
And they can be
really wonderfully,
wonderfully inventive.
SPEAKER: If we talked about
movies for the previous books,
this one was adapted
into a ballet.
What's the story behind it?
How can it be?
JONATHAN SAFRAN
FOER: So actually,
the artist I mentioned, Olafur
Eliasson, who said that thing
about the book having a body--
he collaborated with a
choreographer, Wayne McGregor,
and a musician,
the XX, that band--
Jamie XX.
And they made a ballet, which
was really quite a spectacle--
pretty amazing.
What did it have to
do with the book?
Not a lot.
I think that they were
inspired by the idea of layers
and layering and creating
content by removing content--
when the absence becomes
the positive rather than
the negative.
And that idea was
a starting point.
But it's not as if they tried to
convey the story that the book
tells in a different form.
SPEAKER: OK.
So now we are moving to 2016.
And by the way, as a
promotion for this new book,
they said the first
book in 11 years,
as if this one does not exist.
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: Well, not
to mention the book we haven't
talked about, which is "Eating
Animals," which is a nonfiction
book, which I actually
spoke about at the Google
campus in wherever it is--
California?
Sun-- I don't even--
SPEAKER: In Mountain View.
JONATHAN SAFRAN
FOER: Mountain View.
Yeah, I spoke about it there.
I had a really
wonderful conversation
that happened-- do you
remember-- with the person who
ran the food system there--
the chef, I guess it is.
I don't know if she's
still there or not.
I just happened to remember
we had half an hour
before, and incredibly
thoughtful person.
And it turned out to be one
of my favorite conversations
of that book tour.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
So anyway, again, I assume
that maybe not everyone
read "Here I Am."
So would you like maybe to read
a short excerpt from this book?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: I can.
I think that's a very safe
assumption, by the way,
that not everybody
has read this book.
If they had, I
wouldn't even bother
showing up to stuff like this.
No, that's a joke, obviously.
SPEAKER: It's a good one.
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: Yeah.
I can read.
Sure.
I have a little
thing I could do,
which I was just
thinking about recently.
So the book takes
place in Washington DC,
where I grew up, over the
course of about six weeks.
And we follow a family through
two crises, one of which
is domestic, which
is a discovered cell
phone that reveals an affair.
And the other is global.
There's an earthquake,
which precipitates
a war in the Middle
East that's so
extreme that the prime
minister of Israel
asks Jews to come back--
in his words, come back--
to Israel to fight
for its survival.
But a lot of the book just
takes place in Washington,
inside this house, inside
of kitchens and bedrooms
and living rooms, as
these family members
interact with each other.
So we have Jacob and Julie
are the married couple.
Three sons-- Sam, Max, and
Benji, who are 12, 10, and 6.
So I'm just going to
read a very short scene.
It's two pages, but it's
almost all dialogue, where--
the book opens with
Sam, the 12-year-old,
having gotten in
trouble in school,
because there was a piece of
paper found on his desk with
a list of totally
inappropriate words--
racist, misogynistic,
homophobic, anti-Semitic,
sexually lewd--
just all the bad words
you could think of.
And there's a question of, did
he actually do anything wrong?
He didn't direct
them at anybody.
They don't seem to refer to
anything other than themselves.
Jacob, that evening,
goes into Sam's room
to sort of have a conversation
with him about it,
and particularly his
use of the N-word, which
is the only word that's
never actually articulated
between two people
who is referred to.
Sam is now explaining,
well, he couldn't possibly
be racist, because his
girlfriend is black.
So he says, "'Dad,
Billie's black,
so how could I be a racist?'
'Billie?' 'The girl
I'm in love with.'
'You have a girlfriend?' 'No.'
'So then I'm confused.'
'I said, she's the girl
that I'm in love with.'
'OK.
And you said Billie,
but a girl, right?'
'Yes.
And she's black, so
how can I be racist?'
'Well, I'm not sure that
that logic quite works.'
'It does,' Sam said."
And his dad said,
"Well, you know
who points out that
some of his best friends
are black, right--
somebody who isn't
comfortable with black people."
said, 'And And Sam says, "None
of my best friends are black."
And his father says, "And
for whatever it's worth,
I'm pretty sure that
African-American is
the preferred nomenclature.'
'Nomenclature?'
'Terminology.'
'Well, shouldn't the guy who's
in love with a black girl be
the one establishing the
nomenclature?'" And Jacob,
the father, said, "'Isn't that
the pot calling the kettle
African-American?'
'Pot?' 'Look, I'm
just joking around.
It's an interesting name.
That's all.
Not a judgment.
You know that you were named
for a great, great uncle who
perished in Birkenau.
With Jews, there always has to
be some significance attached.
'Some suffering, you mean.
You know, Gentiles just
pick names that sound nice,
or they even make them up.
Billie was named after
Billie Holiday,' Sam said.
'All right.
So fine, she's the exception
that proves the rule.'
'Who were you named
after,' Sam asked,
his interest a small concession
in response to the guilt
of having forced his dad's voice
into quiet sadness earlier.
'I was named for a
distant relative Yacov--
supposedly an amazing,
larger-than-life guy.
Story goes, he crushed a
Cossack's head in his hand.
'Cool.' 'Well, I'm obviously
not strong like that.
We don't even know any Cossacks.
And at most, I'm
the size of life.'
One of their stomachs grumbled,
but neither knew whose.
'Well,' Jacob
said, 'bottom line,
I think it's awesome that
you have a girlfriend.'
'She's not my girlfriend.'
'Nomenclature strikes twice.
I think it's awesome
that you're in love.'
'I'm not in love.
I love her.' 'Well, whatever is
going on, this obviously stays
between us.
You can count on me.'
'I've already talked
to Mom about it.'
'Really?
When?' 'I don't know--
a couple of weeks ago.'
'Wait a minute,
this is old news?'
Jacob stared at Sam's screen.
Was this what drew Sam to it--
not the ability to be
elsewhere but to be nowhere?
'What did you tell her?'
Jacob asked.
'Who?' 'Your mother.'
'You mean Mom?' 'Yeah,
that's the one.'
'I don't know.' 'You don't
know as in, you don't feel like
talking about it
with me right now?'
'Yeah, as in that.'
'It's strange, because she's
convinced that you did write
those words.'
'I didn't,' Sam said.
'OK, I'm becoming annoying.
I'll get out of here.'
'I didn't say you
were annoying.'
Jacob moved to the door
to leave but then paused.
'You want to hear a joke?'
'No,' Sam said.
'It's dirty.' 'Then
definitely no.'
'All right.
What's the difference between
a Subaru and an erection?'
'No means no, Dad.'
'No, no, seriously,
what's the difference?'
'No, no, no, seriously,
not interested.'
Jacob leaned forward
and whispered,
'I don't have a Subaru.'
Despite himself, Sam
released a huge laugh--
the kind involving
snorting and saliva.
And Jacob laughed--
not at his own joke,
but at his son's laughter.
They laugh together
vigorously, hysterically.
Sam struggled, without success,
to regain his composure
and said, 'The funny thing--
the really funny thing--
is you do have a Subaru.'
And then they laughed more.
And Jacob spit a
little and teared up
and remembered how horrible
it was to be Sam's age--
how painful and unfair.
'It's true,' Jacob said.
'I totally have a Subaru.
I should have said Toyota.
What was I thinking?'
'What were you thinking?'
What was he thinking?"
Stop there.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: After I
read this book--
and it was when it
came out in hardback--
there was kind of a very
strange rhyming event for me,
because I was driving my car
almost a few days after I
finished reading it.
And I heard, over the radio, a
new Leonard Cohen song, which
is called "You Want it Darker."
I guess you know it.
Again, I just read just
the first couple of lines.
It said, "If you are the
dealer, I'm out of the game.
If you are the healer, it
means I'm broken and lame.
If thine is the glory, then
mine must be the shame.
You want it darker,
we kill the flame."
And then he comes to the chorus
and he said, ""[NON-ENGLISH]..
I'm ready, my Lord.
[NON-ENGLISH].
I'm ready."
"Here I am" in Hebrew.
And again, I was wondering,
is this kind of magic?
What would you read into
this kind of thing--
that two very important artists
came up with this important
of using [NON-ENGLISH]
or "here I am"
as part of whatever they
are doing that moment?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: Well,
it's only [NON-ENGLISH],,
"here I am."
It's also "I'm ready,"
as you just said,
which are the last
two words of this book
and have a huge significance
as the last two words.
It's just a total coincidence.
Things can be sort of
culturally in the air.
"Magically" was
the word you used.
And it's not a bad word.
But it's not
magical in the sense
that it defies explanation.
It's just magical in the
sense that the explanation
is so wonderful--
that there's kind
of something like
a collective consciousness.
There are the ideas that
people have independently
and powerfully.
And the reality is that this
is happening all the time.
It's just that we only get to
witness it every now and again.
The things that seem like
profound coincidences really
aren't.
It's just that the ability to be
present when they're happening
is rare.
But their occurrence, in and
of itself, is not that rare.
There's also, at
the exact same time,
in the TV show "Transparent,"
which I really love,
there was an episode in which
[NON-ENGLISH] and "here I am"
also took on a
great significance.
SPEAKER: Maybe I'll stop here.
And if anyone in the audience
has some questions to you
as well, then this
might be a good time.
AUDIENCE: So to go
back earlier when
you were talking about the--
I don't know-- the art project
book and you mentioned that
you'd hope that we would be
mindful of the qualities that
we're losing as we move to
other forms of media, it seems,
to me, also that there are a lot
of qualities that we gained--
like, all the qualities
that you listed
having to do with books
that you said were trivial
were things that were not
present when stories were just
transmitted orally.
And I wondered, do you feel
like there's a net loss?
Or do you think it's
just the qualities
that we gained by going to
ebooks or whatever else?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER:
I'm definitely not making
the argument that technology
leads to less qualities
necessarily.
But it's just something that's
worth thinking about it.
That was my only point.
In the specific case of going
from a paper book to an ebook,
presently, I don't know
what an ebook offers,
beyond the obvious things,
which are wonderful convenience,
which is great.
And it gives one the
ability to carry many books
at the same time
or to have access
to books that you
wouldn't necessarily
have in a bookstore.
And those are wonderful things.
But in terms of the
reading experience,
I don't find the quality of
reading a book on the screen
to be as rich as reading a book.
That having been said,
the ebook experience
is obviously going to
change in the coming years.
And because of that, the
nature of books will change.
And there will be
the expectation
to have all kinds of
ancillary material
and that you'll be able to
link to the author talking
about why he or she made a
decision in a certain point.
Or you'll be able to--
I assume one can
already do this.
I just don't really
swim in that water.
But you could click
on a line that you
are sure is an
allusion to something
and then Shakespeare
will open up or Faulkner
or whatever it was.
So I get frustrated
when people talk
about the inherent good or the
inherent bad of technology.
It's just such an
oversimplification.
And it's naive, and
it's unproductive.
But I also get
frustrated when there
isn't an honest and
robust conversation
about what it is
that we're losing
as we are gaining these things.
As somebody said to
me the other day,
technology now runs the
risk of answering questions
it doesn't ask.
And there are massive
changes afoot,
in terms of what it
is to be a human being
and how we relate to each other.
And I'm so grateful for a
lot of the things that--
is that true?
Am I so grateful?
Maybe I'm not.
I don't know.
But I'm not dismissive of
the new ways of communicating
with other people.
I think there
probably are examples
in which it makes me
feel more human, as
opposed to simply presenting
the illusion of offering
more and more time,
which it does not do.
But what I don't
think is I don't
think that there are broad ways
of together asking questions
about not simply,
what is efficient,
and not simply, what is
attractive in a short-term
sense, but what is good?
It's a very basic question.
We were saying earlier,
Google has had the mantra as--
this is, again, to an outside
or a lay person of-- what is it?
Do no evil, or don't be evil?
Don't be evil.
That's an awfully
low bar to clear.
There is another question to be
asked, which is, what would it
mean to do good and to
think very deliberately
about, is there a difference
in quality of thought?
Is one kind of thought better
than another kind of thought
that makes us feel--
I don't want anybody to be
the arbiter of that question.
But we are living in
a world in which there
are arbiters of such questions.
Google and Facebook
and Twitter--
they are the arbiters of
how should humans think,
because the form doesn't
predetermine or dictate.
But it strongly
influences the kinds
of interactions that
we have and the kinds
of thoughts that we have.
And it's nice to imagine that
the goodness of the quality
of those thoughts is something
that is as seriously considered
as any other question.
AUDIENCE: 9/11 is
a pretty big topic
to take on since,
for many of us,
it looms large in
our recent memory.
We're in college or
wherever we were, many of us
were living it when it happened.
Did this feel like a
big challenge for you
to take on such a big topic?
Did you decide, I want
to write a 9/11 book
and then the characters came
out of that or vice versa?
Can you just say
anything about the topic
as it fit into your
writing process?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: It
was a very difficult thing
to write about.
I was helped by the
fact that I didn't
know I was writing about it.
If I were to know what
I was doing in advance
of trying to do it, most of
the things that I write about,
I just wouldn't do.
And a lot of my writing is the
result of a very open process
that isn't outcome-oriented.
I'm not trying to write a book
about anything in particular.
I never find a voice
that I want to share.
There are never characters
living inside of me.
There's no story that
I'm burning to tell.
It's a very open process--
open to intuitions,
open to distractions,
open to my changing self
and the changing world.
Most writers require two years
to write a book or three years.
You change over
that period of time.
And the world changes.
And I would never want to be
in the position of responding
or being enslaved to what
seemed like a good idea had
by somebody that I no
longer am in a world
that we no longer live in.
So I like books to bend.
In the case of "Extremely
Loud," I literally
didn't know that I was
writing about September 11
for quite a long time.
I had had this boy Oscar
whose father died tragically
somehow, very suddenly.
And he had a lot of the same
characteristics and phobias
that he has now.
He used imagination in a
lot a lot of the same ways.
And I actually gave the
book to my little brother
who said to me, is
it possible you're
writing about September 11?
There's a certain quality of
idea that once you hear it,
it becomes so obvious.
But before hearing it, you never
would have had it yourself.
And that was such an idea.
But all writing is hard, I find.
I find it's all
difficult. And the idea
of taking on a challenging
subject, consciously or not,
what else would you be doing?
Why wouldn't you be trying
to approach the big concerns?
A big concern doesn't have to
be a big historical concern.
And it doesn't
have to be tragic.
Humor can just as powerfully
address the big concerns.
But it's always tough.
I have a friend who
is a writer-- he's
no longer alive,
unfortunately-- who used to say,
writing is like pulling
teeth out of your penis.
It's as tough as it comes.
For somebody who believes
that writing has the ability
to organize one's thoughts
and feelings and the ability
to organize them in a way
that they can be shared--
well, that's a big tool to have.
And so you wouldn't want
to use the proton collider.
Is that what it's called?
The electron collider?
What is it?
SPEAKER: Collider
definitely is in there.
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: Yes.
And it's probably
in Switzerland.
But actually, if I could
run back to the men's room,
I'm sure there's an explanation
of it above the urinal.
But you wouldn't want to
use that to scramble eggs.
That would be a stupid
use of an amazing tool.
The novel is an
amazing tool and should
be used in a way that
befits its potential.
AUDIENCE: Again, I
have two questions.
One is easy.
And then one, I haven't
figured out how to ask.
The easy one kind of
relates to the question
asked about making the movies.
I listened to "Here I
Am" as an audio book
and wondered to
what extent you had
any involvement in
that-- if you've
heard it, if you enjoyed it.
I really thought the
narrator did a fabulous job
and was a good way
to enjoy the book.
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: So
we'll answer that while you
think about your second one.
I haven't heard it.
I haven't, because I
have a kind of resistance
to it, not in the sense that
I'm worried about its quality.
I've actually heard only
good things about it.
And I'm grateful for
the person who did it.
But it would be awkward
for me to listen to,
in much the same
way that listening
to your voice on an
answering machine
is awkward, just
multiplied by 100 million.
I've heard really funny
stories of people who
are listening to the audiobook.
They're bopping around in their
convertible with the windows
down.
It's a nice day.
Come to a red light.
Cars on the left,
cars on the right.
And then it gets
to the part about--
there's some pretty sexually
explicit stuff in this book--
stuff where I very deliberately
wrote the crudest thing I
could conceive of, because
it had to be for the context,
because it's examining
the power of language,
examining the relationship
between words and action.
And also, it had to be
something that there
was no way for Jacob, the
husband, to be able to say,
well, it's not what it seems.
It had to be undeniably awful.
And so I've heard stories of
people who are reading a book--
and those things
come out of the blue.
They're not contextualized
in the beginning--
reading the book and then
all of a sudden, it's--
you can imagine.
AUDIENCE: That was actually
the first thing [INAUDIBLE]..
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: You
needed the [INAUDIBLE]
to talk about it.
AUDIENCE: When I
saw the pile there,
I wanted to see
the physical copy
so that I could see how it
was presented in the book,
because I remember it
being jarring in the car,
especially until the
story kind of evolved
to interpret what was going on.
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: Yeah.
In the book, it's
these sexting sentences
that are taken out of context.
But in the book, they're removed
from the body of the text
by a space.
And they're centered,
and they're in italics.
So when you read it,
there's no question
that you're reading something
that is out of context.
And I've wondered how a
voice would accomplish that.
Do you want to
try to imitate it?
AUDIENCE: It's
not safe for work.
The harder question was--
and I wish I could think
of specific examples.
But there certain--
I don't know-- either
paragraphs or sentences
or phrases or concepts that seem
almost as if they're poetic.
They're within the
context of the book.
And I wonder if it's things
you collect over time, thoughts
you have just as
you live your life,
and it's time to present
them in the book,
or if, as you're writing and--
I don't know-- in the flow of
telling your story or thinking
about it--
the things I'm referring to
is maybe like scrapbook pieces
that--
important thoughts that you've
had are coming to you in line
as you create the
book, or if they're
things you've wanted to say
and here's an opportunity
to say so, even if
that wasn't where
you imagined them showing up.
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: That's
a really wonderful question.
And I'm not even sure I
know the answer exactly.
I can tell you a
little bit about how
I write in the course of each
day, which may be my best
way of answering that.
So when I face the
blank page or screen,
I devote the beginning of
each day to a kind of almost
free associative thought.
So I will sit down
and just ask myself,
is there something I'm
thinking about right now?
Is there anything on my mind?
And I might literally look
around the room and just,
does anything here capture
my imagination right now?
And it's not a
judgment of the thing.
It's a judgment of my
imagination in that moment.
It's not even a judgment at all.
It's just a description of it.
So like, right now, I
can look around the room
and think, these lighting--
doesn't really do
anything for me.
The exit sign
that's illuminated,
kind of interesting.
Maybe I'll come back to that.
These chairs-- a globe--
so anyway, I would
find something and just
reflect on it and
research it a little bit
and write for an hour or
two about some thing that
just captures my mind
with absolutely no regard
or concern for the outcome--
if it's going to fit into what
I'm working on, if it's useful.
It's just, I assume there
is some good reason that I'm
interested in something.
It's a little bit like--
I don't know if you ever have
the experience of getting
into bed on Friday
night after a long day
at the end of a long week.
You're really tired.
The room is cold.
The bed is warm.
And you're about to drift off.
And then you have a little idea.
And you think, well, I could get
out of bed and write it down,
or I could just assume
that it's not important,
or I can assume that I'll
remember it in the morning.
But nobody ever,
ever, ever remembers
those ideas in the morning.
So writing, the way I do it, is
a lot like getting out of bed.
It's uncomfortable.
It's not the easier
way to do things.
And I'm not at all sure
that these thoughts are
going to have any significance.
But I know that I can't
know unless I record them
and I'm able to
reflect on them later.
So I spend the first bit of
every writing day doing that.
Then I go back to the beginning
of what I have been working
on for the last
stretch of time--
so let's say a 50-page section--
and I'll read it
from the beginning,
editing it while I read it.
So I'm constantly
editing what I work on.
I don't make a draft and then a
second draft and a third draft.
It's always combing over itself.
And then at the end of the day,
when I have maybe an hour left,
I will look back at the
thing from the beginning--
at the globe or
whatever it was--
and think, is this interesting?
Does this have anything
to do with anything?
Was it just a little
piece of mental garbage
that had to be disposed
of, or is it relevant?
And when I'm in the
beginning of a book
and I don't yet have a
feeling for what it is,
that stuff at the
beginning of the day
is almost always nothing.
I can't use it.
As I get to the end of a
book, four days out of five,
it ends up becoming part
of what I'm working on.
And I can think of so many
explicit examples in this book.
There's little meditations on
contingency plans for asteroids
approaching the earth.
There's a little meditation
on sign language.
There's the meditation
on this Nirvana lyric.
There's a meditation
on the animals
in the Museum of Natural
History and why their positioned
in the ways that they are.
Those are all the products
of that early morning "I'm
thinking about this
thing right now"
and then the realization that
the part of the brain that you
don't have control over
is constantly at work
and is constantly
doing interesting work,
as opposed to the
part of the brain
that I do have
control over, which
is eating a lot of popcorn
and watching a lot of TV
and, even when it is
engaged, isn't that great.
It's OK, but it's
not that great.
I would never be able to write
something good on purpose.
It always has to be
because I have learned,
through lots of experience
and lots of effort and will--
it's not naive--
but I have learned how to
get in the way of those kind
of interesting accidents
and how to move
the light toward my intuitions.
AUDIENCE: So I've read
a number of your books.
"Eating Animals" is one of
them, albeit seven years ago.
But from what I remember,
you touch a little bit
upon this forgetfulness
that happens
when there's a lack of
transparency into something.
And transparency's a really
interesting topic, especially
in the tech space
at both extremes.
And so I'm wondering,
A, what your thoughts
are on that, and B, If you
might have another nonfiction
book in the works
that also touch--
or if you were particularly
attached to the animal topic,
or if you're really
interested in the meta topics?
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER: That's
another really great question.
For a long time, I've wanted to
write a book about technology,
actually.
And in a way, that's very
similar to "Eating Animals"--
that I've had these
instincts about it,
and they seem to fluctuate
in really extreme ways.
And they're based in not a lot--
not a lot of familiarity with
how the world actually works
and what's actually going on.
And with "Eating Animals,"
it wasn't until--
and for most of my life, I
was sometimes a vegetarian.
Sometimes I would
eat everything.
Sometimes I was a vegan.
Sometimes I was a pescatarian--
just all over the map.
I've had periods
when I will leave
my phone in a drawer for as
much of the day as possible
or leave my phone
in the drawer when
I'm in my house with family.
I don't use any social media.
But I could also easily imagine
becoming deeply immersed in it.
I'm somebody who's flailing
in his relationship
to technology, just as I flailed
in my relationship to food.
It was when I had kids and
had to start making choices
on their behalf, because
every parent does.
It's not like you force
vegetarianism on your kid
any more than you force
meat-eating on your kids.
You just force a familial
culture on your kids.
That is what it
is to be a parent.
And similarly, I now have
to give some really serious
thought to what kind
of role technology
will play in their lives.
And I'd like for it
to be thoughtful--
not the kind of
thought that is just
following the current of
whatever everybody else is
doing or the current
of what is easy,
but where my actions are in
some kind of correspondence
with my beliefs.
As I was saying earlier,
as with the food industry,
I think everybody feels a little
bit of discomfort with regard
to meat.
Anthony Bourdain feels a little
discomfort with regard to meat.
We've had
conversations about it.
He's actually an incredibly
thoughtful person about it.
It's just, he distinguishes
between factory farming
and traditional
and family farming,
which I think is an extremely
important distinction
to make that a lot of people
don't know about or think
about.
I think also there's a broad
discomfort about technology.
I don't know any
parents who have
a perfectly laissez-faire
attitude about technology when
it comes to their kids.
And frankly, I don't
know all that many people
who have a perfectly
laissez-faire attitude
about their own use.
If I had a nickel for every
time somebody has said to me,
I wish I used my phone less,
I wish I checked email less,
I wish I were less
reliant on screens--
not that I wish I didn't
have them in my life.
That's not what I mean.
And these are people who
love the technology that they
have and value it in ways that I
think are really rich and deep,
but a discomfort.
That's all-- a discomfort.
And it's a discomfort
that I, at least,
haven't devoted nearly enough
of myself to and want to,
especially as the influence
of technology in our lives
is becoming something
that is not only
more profound, but
harder to negotiate
as the range of
choices seems to be
becoming smaller and smaller.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering about--
I remember there was a scene
in "Extremely Loud" where Oscar
discovers the pen
in the pen store
where it's written
in a different color.
And that's one of those things
that just has stuck with me.
I go and I look at pens.
And it's like,
oh, wouldn't it be
funny to write a
different color?
Is that one of those things
that was an early morning
kind of thing?
Or is that one of those
things that kind of floats
through the air and
then you remember it
for a long time, kind
of looking for a way
to weave that into a story?
Because that seemed like--
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER:
That's a great question.
So he's referring to the
phenomenon of anybody
who's ever been to an
office supply store
where there's a little
pad of paper where
people can test pens.
They very often write the
name of the color of the pen
that they're writing with.
And that ends up
being a kind of clue
or an oddity that Oscar notices.
That was something
that struck me--
so there's a whole category
of things that just strike me
as interesting metaphors
without my knowing what
they're metaphors for.
Those, to me, are the most
richest kind of metaphors.
Like, this has something
to do with life,
and I don't know what.
If I know what it is, then
it's a little bit mundane,
or it exhausts itself.
And if I don't trust that it has
anything to do with anything,
then it's just empty.
But there's something
in between where
you're not able to
grasp the meaning,
but you know that it's there.
And that's a really
deep experience
to have as a writer or a
reader or just a person
moving through the world.
I write scenes around
those feelings.
So you might have
read that scene
and thought, OK, so he
has Oscar doing this,
and then he was thinking
about a stationery store
and he had that realization.
In fact, I wrote the whole
stationery store scene
because I had had that idea.
Another example-- actually,
is it the cover of this?
Can I see that "Extremely Loud?"
SPEAKER: Sure.
JONATHAN SAFRAN FOER:
Well, it's not exactly--
there's an image in the book
that this is an excerpt from.
It's right here.
It's in the beginning.
This.
So this photo takes on some
significance in the book.
There's a two-page spread of it.
The first book I ever did,
which we didn't talk about,
was an anthology about
the artist Joseph Cornell.
The publisher paid
me for that book--
it was an art book
publisher-- in art books.
So I had a huge credit.
And every season,
they would send me
the catalog of their books.
And I would pick out
the ones that I liked.
And they would send them to me.
And that was how we
worked off the advance.
In one of those
catalogs, this was
the cover of a book
called, I think,
the "Birdman of Brooklyn."
I think so.
I just became entranced
by that cover.
I said, I'd like
to order that book.
And they said, we're
actually not publishing it.
I can't remember
what had happened.
There was some problem.
And yet, I had seen the image.
And then I got in touch with the
photographer, who I befriended.
And then I wrote the
scene for the book
as a way of using that image.
And it's the scene in which
the title "Extremely Loud
and Incredibly Close" appears--
the only time in the book.
And it's because of the--
talk about the process
of openness and fortuity.
There's a wonderful saying
that the Russian poet Joseph
Brodsky said, "The rhyme
is smarter than the poet."
People write in verse
because it's pretty,
but also because it
creates a problem.
And the solution
to the problem is
more interesting than what you
would have done if you had not
been constrained.
I would never have
arrived at the title
"Extremely Loud and
Incredibly Close."
I would never have had the scene
where Oscar goes and visits
the guy with the hearing aid--
turning the hearing aid up--
if I hadn't come across
this thing, which,
in a way, my attraction
to that image
presented a problem, which
is, how can I use that?
And the solution to it was,
in many ways, this book.
And just to return to a
theme that has come up now--
I know we have to
end-- but in addition
to where are the qualities,
where are the problems?
We're living in a world that's
solving all of our problems
for us.
Is there anything
richer than getting--
it's frustrating.
It's annoying, and
it is to be avoided.
But how many good things
have been stumbled
upon when you get lost?
The most memorable experiences
that I have had as a driver--
virtually all of them are
either because I was lost
or because I
created my own route
and, in the process
of creating it,
became aware of possibilities.
Like, oh, god, I've always
meant to go to that place.
Or you've got to be
kidding me, there's
a town with this bizarre name?
I have to have a picture
of myself at the--
and it is something else
that I give a lot of thought
to, because so much
of my creative life
is dependent upon the accidental
thing which is stumbled
upon which I commit
myself to exploring
and to being in response to--
not that the accidents--
the world is not in
the service of me--
of facilitating the
world so that it's better
organized for my
ends, but that I
can be also in the service of
those wonderful, stumbled-upon
things.
SPEAKER: Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]